on the surface Android is the free
open-source operating system that runs
the world Android has over 3 billion
active users and over a billion Android
phones are sold every single year but
unlike true open source software like
Linux which is run by a nonprofit
Foundation Android is run by Google and
I'm sure you've figured that this leads
to some ulterior motives by giving out
Android for free Google is able to drive
billions of users to all of their
prominent products whether that's Gmail
Google Maps Google search Google
Assistant Google Drive you name it all
of this obviously adds up to quite a bit
of auxiliary Revenue but Google also has
much more direct methods of monetizing
Android as well in fact it turns out
that Android isn't actually free at all
since 2018 Google has been charging
phone makers up to $40 per device
technically this fee isn't for Android
itself but all of the Google apps that
come along with Android but if we're
being honest Google Apps and Android are
pretty much synonymous at this point so
phone makers are basically forced to pay
this licensing fee and let's not forget
about the crown jewel of Android the
Google Play Store the Google Play Store
generates up to $48 billion in Revenue
per year over 23 of which has
historically been profit let me put that
in perspective you know Windows the big
software Monopoly run by Microsoft that
controls 69% of the desktop Market well
Windows as a whole only generated $24.7
billion through all of 2022 in other
words Android generates twice the
revenue of Windows using just the Google
Play Store alone with that being said I
should mention that Android also does
cost Google a lot of money to maintain
in fact according to Google's lawyers
Google has spent over $40 billion to
support Android over the years but with
more Revenue than that coming in from
just the play store every single year I
supect that Google is doing just fine so
here's the insane economics of Android
and how much Android is really worth to
[Music]
Google starting from the sale of Android
phones we have the fee that Google
charges Android phone makers while this
fee can be as high as $40 per device the
good news is that not everyone actually
pays this much if you opt to include
minimal Google services on your version
of Android you can get away with paying
us little less $2.50 per device but
according to google themselves the
majority of phone makers will end up
paying around $20 per device and at this
point phone makers have been selling
over a billion Android phones every
single year for the last decade so I
think it's safe to estimate that Android
phone sales alone are pulling in at
least $20 billion for Google annually
and that's before the real monetization
even begins next up we of course have
the Google Play Store the Apple App
Store tends to Garner a lot more media
headlines because they do generate a lot
more Revenue than the Play Store in 2021
they generated 85 bill billion dollar or
nearly twice the revenue of the Play
Store despite having less than half the
users but just because the Apple App
Store is more lucrative and takes all
the media heat doesn't mean that the
Play Store is not lucrative Google likes
to claim that they have a super
developer friendly pricing model where
97% of developers don't even have to pay
a fee but that's just because 97% of
Play Store developers don't make any
sort of substantial revenue or they
don't use Google's payment
infrastructure when it comes to apps
that that are actually performing well
and rely on Google's payment
infrastructure for Revenue whether that
be paid apps or inapp purchases the Play
Store pretty much has the exact same
pricing model as the Apple App Store if
your app makes less than $1 million per
year Apple charges a tax of 15% and if
your app makes more than $1 million per
year they charge a tax of
30% now you want to guess what Google
charges well if your app makes less than
$1 million per year Google charges 15%
and if your app makes more than $
million per year Google charges 30%
Google also charges 15% on subscription
products like streaming services and up
to 15% on all other transactions so
despite being the free open- source OS
Android has the same pricing as Apple's
closed private OS but since iPhone users
are more likely to spend money on apps
Apple takes all the heat for this
pricing model in the meantime Android is
quietly racking in as much as $48
billion per year A couple of years ago
in a lawsuit between Oracle and Google
oracle's lawyers estimated that out of
the 31 billion in Revenue that the Play
Store is making at the time 22 billion
was profit AKA
70% even if this has dropped closer to
66% we're looking at $32 billion profit
from just the play store alone for
perspective Google as a whole only makes
$78 billion in profit per year so the
Play Store alone might account for as
much as 41% of Google's entire bottom
line when you combine this with
licensing fees from phone makers were
left with a total of $68 billion worth
of direct revenue from Android or a
little over a fifth of Google's entire
revenue and all of that is just from
direct monetization Google's indirect
monetization efforts are far more
[Music]
interesting given that Google apps come
pre-installed on Android devices
billions of users are driven towards
these apps every single year but I don't
think you quite realize just how
lucrative this is personally I always
assume that the split between mobile
revenue and desktop Revenue was more or
less equal but it turns out that mobile
is actually far more profitable across
the board especially when it comes to
certain apps like Google Maps Morgan
Stanley estimates that Google Maps
Revenue will total $1 billion in 2023
out of which 9.82 billion or 90% is
thanks to mobile devices for all obvious
reasons Maps is more skewed towards
mobile devices than other Google apps
but this trend holds across the board in
fact over 70% of YouTube watch time
comes from mobile devices and 63% of all
Google searches also come from mobile
devices it's not just users who prefer
mobile either it turns out that
advertisers also like to spend a lot
more money on mobile ads 60% of global
digital ad spend comes from mobile
devices so there's no question that
controlling a mobile OS is lucrative
even more lucrative than controlling a
desktop OS but it's a lot harder to
quantify this thankfully Google has
already put a number on this with their
partnership with apple you know how
Safari and Siri and other Apple Services
direct you to Google search well this
isn't out of the kindness of Apple's
heart or some sort of affinity for
Google the reality is that Google
actually pays Apple a boatload of money
for Google to be the primary search
engine on Apple devices $18 billion per
year to be precise and that that's just
for Google search to be the default
search engine it has nothing to do with
maps or photos or drive or Gmail or
Chrome or any of the other goog services
that come pre-installed on Android
devices some of these Services people
would likely use regardless of whether
it's pre-installed or not for example
people aren't going to switch from Gmail
to Outlook just because the Gmail app
does or does not come pre-installed
similarly people aren't going to switch
from YouTube to Daily Motion just
because Android doesn't come with
YouTube
so for certain apps the benefit of
controlling Android is not that large
but for other apps it makes all the
difference like maps for example when
Apple launched their own version of maps
in 2012 the vast majority of iPhone
users were extremely disappointed but by
simply continuing to put it in front of
people and improving the platform Apple
was able to increase Apple Maps usage to
be three times higher than Google Maps
usage on iOS devices by the end of 2015
itself so by this point it's it's likely
that 80 to 90% of iPhone users just use
Apple Maps considering that Google's
ability to force Google maps onto
Android users is extremely valuable out
of the 9.82 billion that Google Maps
generates from mobile devices likely 7
to 8 billion is directly thanks to
Android another instance in which the OS
makes a big difference is cloud storage
Apple hasn't released iCloud stats in a
while but as of 2018 they had 850
million iCloud users out of which 170
million we're paying by now that number
is likely closer to 250 or 300 million
paying users each paying user only
generates about $2 to $3 in Revenue per
month but at that scale it adds up to
roughly $8 billion per year now iCloud
is great and all but it's likely that
most of these users just use iCloud
because it's already there it's part of
Apple's ecosystem and it just works it's
likely the same case with Google photos
and drive as well a lot of people who
use and pay for the those Services
likely do it just because it's already
there it's part of the Google ecosystem
and it just works combine this with the
18 billion that Google thinks that
mobile search is worth and the 78
billion from maps and we're already up
to $34 billion in indirect monetization
we can easily throw on more Google
services on top of this like Chrome and
Google assistant and Google Docs and
Google meet and Google Calendar and we'd
probably end up with something like $50
billion combine this with their 68
billion from their direct monetization
efforts and were're left with $118
billion in Revenue to be conservative we
can even call it 100 billion which
brings us into the question of the day
how much does Android Worth to
[Music]
Google well keeping things simple Google
pulls in just under $300 billion worth
of Revenue every year and they're worth
$1.67 trillion so given that Android
itself conservatively accounts for 100
billion of this you could say that
Android is worth $550 billion that would
nearly make Android a top 10 Company by
itself no wonder Google wanted Android's
founder Andy Rubin to be the next CEO of
Google until he got caught up in a
scandal Android is obviously not the
open-source free software that Google
likes to position it as but honestly
putting aside the insane economics of
Android the true value of Android is
much more than just Financial Gam
Android gives Google power over the
entire smartphone experience of over 3
billion people this gives them
unprecedented access into the inner
workings of every aspect of these
people's online and personal lives what
are their interests how much money do
they make how does their family life
look like where do they spend their
money how do their political beliefs
look like and so much more that I can
never truly list out because Google
takes full advantage of this each
Android device sends Google 1 Megabyte
of data every 12 hours even when left
idle for perspective each iOS device
only sends Apple 52 KOB or 12th of the
data every 12 hours this means that
Android collects 2 megabytes of data
every day from every Android User even
if they're not actively using their
phones from the entire 3.3 billion
Android user base that translates to 6.6
paby of data every single day or 2.4
exabytes of data every single year
Google likes to a search that this does
not accurately depict their data
collection efforts because a lot of this
data is just software updates and device
status related things but just because a
lot of it is harmless doesn't mean that
all of it is and considering that
Google's entire business model is
collecting data and showing ads it's
likely that a good amount of it is more
than what you'd be comfortable sharing
things like location data search history
phone usage online purchases and even
Biometrics of 3.3 billion people and
that right there there is the real power
of Android the $100 billion in revenue
from Android is really just a bonus with
the historically High interest rates the
appeal of bills and bonds is higher than
ever yet traditional brokerages haven't
really adapted with the times they still
expect people to use clunky Bond tables
scroll through long overwhelming lists
and even use Virtual keyboards till
recently and that's why we created our
own modern Bond platform Silo at silo we
prioritize the user experience and the
ease of finding and investing in the
issuers you know and trust so that you
too can easily lock in high yields also
choosing a strong user experience does
not mean sacrificing on safety every
salow account is insured by $500,000 in
sipc insurance and $2.5 million in FDIC
Insurance also all funds deposited on
the platform will be maintained by our
trusted custodian interactive brokers
who has experienced managing 373 billion
dollar worth of assets over the past 45
years so if you're looking for a modern
way to invest in bonds please consider
checking out Silo in the description
below not all as well within the Android
Empire though in fact they've been
slowly bleeding market share to Apple
for years now check out this video to
learn more but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next
one